let's talk about Scott Adams ladies and
gentlemen we have this tweet from Scott
Adams he says my publisher for
non-dilbert books has canceled my
upcoming book and the entire backlist
still no disagreement about my point of
view my book agent canceled me too I'm
not sure what he means by still no
disagreement about his point of view but
uh here's the story because there's a
lot of people disagreeing with this
point of view
hundreds of Islam hot air hundreds of
newspapers canceled Dilbert comic strip
accused Scott Adams of racism there is
some Nuance to the conversation being
had here that the media is overlooking
in what Scott Adams said albeit I
disagree with what Scott Adams
prescription for the prop for the for
the issue is
Rasmussen published this
black Americans only quote it's okay to
be white 53 agree 26 percent disagree 21
not sure that's kind of a crazy scary
number that 26 of black Americans think
it's are they disagree with the idea
that it's okay to be white and 21 aren't
sure that's kind of scary quote black
people can be racist too 76 percent
agree 27 disagree eight percent not sure
so let me play for you what Scott Adams
said which resulted in his absolute
cancellation Dilbert's being canceled
his book is being canceled he says his
career is over here's what he said so if
if you know nearly half of All Blacks uh
are not okay with
no bring to this poll not according to
me
according to this poll
that's a hate group
and I don't want to have anything to do
with them
and I would say you know based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the away
wherever you have to go just get away
because there's no fixing this
can't be fixed
all right this can't be fixed you just
have to escape
so that's what I did I went to a
neighborhood where you know I have a
very low black population
because unfortunately there you know
there's High correlation between the
density and this is going to Don Lemon
by the way
um so here I'm just quoting Don Lemon
when when he notes that the when he
lived in a mostly black neighborhood
there were a bunch of problems they
didn't see in white neighborhoods
so even Don Lemon sees a big difference
in your own quality of living
based on where you live and who's there
so I think it makes no sense whatsoever
as a white citizen of America to try to
help black citizens anymore
it doesn't make sense it is no longer a
rational
impulse
and so I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna back off from being helpful to
Black America because it doesn't seem
like it pays off
like I've been doing it all my life and
I've been the only outcome is I get
called a racist
that's the only outcome
it makes no sense to help black
Americans if you're white the the it's
over
don't don't even think it's worth trying
totally not trying
and
there we go
you didn't expect that today did you so
I don't get what his point is I mean
first of all he's he's very very wrong
uh he makes the point about Don Lemon
saying even in these neighborhoods I'm
like yeah Don Lemon did say that Don
Lemon did this thing in 2013 where he
was like if you live in the black
community stop littering start doing
these things and then I just brought up
like I don't know about these other
cities I know that in Chicago and Hyde
Park which has double the black
population on average than the than the
country's average it's actually very
wealthy and very nice and has some as
University of Chicago and uh you walk
around and everything is beautiful down
there for the most part and you go to
other neighborhoods like where I grew up
and there's a bunch of scummy white
trash white people with you know cars no
tires in the front of their house and
and trash like that so I I I don't know
maybe it's just me because I'm in the in
the mix of it I don't see that I don't
know what he's talking about but uh now
his book is canceled
his non-dilbert books are canceled his
entire backlist here's here's what I
think when the left has psychotic racist
opinions nobody bats an eye nobody gets
canceled the left can literally advocate
for racial segregation and they do and
they implement it all the time and
there's no repercussions and then Scott
Adams comes out and says he doesn't like
this so he's going to move and he thinks
other people should as well and I'm like
I disagree with you Scott Adams I don't
I don't like stereotyping based on a
race that doesn't solve the problem and
it doesn't actually get to the root of
what is actually going on just because
they pulled this group of people doesn't
actually answer any of the questions
that we're trying to have answered but
uh but that's fine he's allowed to have
his opinion I'm just saying there's
clearly leftist crt-based racism which
is very very similar in many ways well I
mean it's literally just like old school
white supremacy with a with a mask put
on it is totally acceptable and fun I'm
not Derek Bell the critical race
theorist who's pro-segregation that's
acceptable in these schools Scott Adams
who says basically the same thing but in
a different way that's really really bad
I think it's all bad but it's clearly
double standard
I think he's been sort of on a slow
cancellation anyways like this is maybe
the nail in his public coffin but he got
dropped by a big public or public
publisher who has like 70 newspapers
earlier last year because he had this
character who's black but identifies as
white and he was making some joke about
like ESG scores and got contacted by
publisher for like I think it was 73
newspapers and they're like we're not
going to run your comic anymore I
understand why this is like
uncomfortable and shocking and I don't
think that he's right about the way he's
interpreting all of this data but I
think that he has been sort of uh
and a uh a growing Target for cancel
culture anyways you're right that about
the way he's interpreting this data is
wrong he took a poll of a thousand
people and then he said something about
all of Americans and that people should
run away from black people because of
this thousand person poll that isn't
even confirmed I don't know if it's
actually 72 Rasmussen said that they
pull online so people elect to take it
and that it's Nationwide so
theoretically people come from a
cross-section of society theoretically
people could lie the people who answer a
poll like that are the people who are
going to answer yeah I mean that's
that's the problem that the gun industry
has the same thing that's one of the
problems with polling right like you if
you just put out one poll and you're
like and we've now decided it's
indicative of something but you would
need to do more research to really get
to the bottom of it and he he says in
the beginning just so you know this is
all based on this one poll I'm basing my
entire belief structure on this poll now
and he starts claiming things as if the
poll is right dude Scott you brought it
on yourself man it is crazy that 26 of
people would be like no it's not okay to
be it's not 26 percent of people 26 of a
thousand people yeah of black
respondents yeah which are worthy even
black I mean can you prove it I can't I
don't know any this poll your question
of trust is not a question of the
argument well he makes a definitive
claim based on this unverifiable poll
and if it is verified it's a thousand
people if this is true that's what the
poll says then therefore then he
extrapolates then therefore the entire
world is that way so we must make
decisions based on well big mistakes
Scott and you're you're not you're not
actually answering what Hannah Claire
was talking about
uh in what way your Hannah clay was
talking about how it's crazy that you
know 26 of the the respondents
identifying this way said this thing now
you can extrapolate whatever 26 of
people that was why 26 of black
respondents said that they think it's
not okay to be white is it 1 000 did you
actually it's 1 000 for the whole poll
yeah I thought it was like 130 I think
that the 26
is a smaller population 30 total
respondents right if I if I remember so
Scott made a broad sweeping Claim about
Society based on 100 he actually said he
moved away because of things like this
and I'm kind of like yeah that's that's
because he already did it he didn't he's
not saying I'm moving he already he
already left right I've been of the
belief that maybe Scott would come on
the show one day like he's been very
vocal about critical race Theory and
like he seems like he's got an awareness
about things in society but at the same
time I gotta say Dilbert I think is one
of the most boring cartoons ever made I
used to watch it in the 80s and 90s or
read it in the 90s in the paper and be
like oh sure it's hot out there today
Han dealer be like yeah he's drinking
coffee he's like got donuts there yeah
and then that's the end of the comic and
you're like what in the hell kind of
dreary
because this comic's boring I I liked
Dilbert because my my dad is a software
engineer and he he is like it is I mean
it was just it was very similar I just
hope that Calvin and Hobbs guy stays out
of this whole District
I don't know how you guys feel about it
if Scott wants to come on I don't know
if you guys are even interested in
talking to the guy but I think you know
I just like I don't like seeing people
get canceled in general I I just like
more information right like I I think
the poll is sort of doing a disservice
because there's no follow-up as far as
we know I mean it's really easy to put
some shocking stats on Twitter and to
not dive into your point right it's only
a thousand people we need more research
to see intensely it is strange that of a
thousand people of the portion that are
African-American they would respond that
like a quarter of them would say it's
not okay to be white that that is
unusual it's not what I would it's it's
unusual but I I think It suffers from
the same problem that you have uh in
like I said with with gun topics you'll
get these polls uh that the anti-gun
Lobby puts out that says ninety percent
of gun owners
um support Universal background checks
and the question is always okay well how
did you phrase the question and and who
did you pull I'm 100 confident that if I
walked into my Jiu Jitsu gym and I
talked to every single black person who
trains there they would look at me like
I was growing a second head yeah I asked
on this question and here and I just
it's so it's like
if you if you go like go outside and
touch grass you know get out into the
real world get away from these polls
like stop stop letting these polls run
your life you know I I can empathize
with the fact that you know like if that
was really true would your advice be
valuable I mean maybe but we'll see
a way to resolved data you're going to
make it worse thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time